THE GREAT SEAN HANNITY FROM THE
NEW YORK.
>> Sean: WHERE YOU COME UP
WITH THIS?
WELCOME TO "HANNITY" AND TONIGHT
AS WE SPEAK, FAKE NEWS OUTLETS
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY, THEY ARE
DROOLING OVER KAMALA HARRIS.
THEY ARE SINGING HER PRAISES.
THEY ARE WRITING WHAT ARE
CRINGEWORTHY FLUFF PIECES TOO OF
COURSE PLEASE THERE ARE LEFT
EDITORS, BUT WHILE THEY LIE TO
YOUR FACE, AGAIN, WE WILL BRING
YOU THE TRUTH.
WE WILL, AS USUAL, DO THE JOB,
THE STATE RUN PROPAGANDA
HATE-TRUMP MEDIA MOB CALLED
REFERS US TO DO.
TONIGHT WE ARE VETTING
KAMALA HARRIS AND IT CONTINUES
IN JUST MOMENTS.
WE WILL CALL OUT HER PHONY
PRAISE OF JOE BIDEN.
AMAZING WHAT A DAY CAN DO AND IT
CAN CHANGE EVERYTHING.
WE WILL ALSO SHOW YOU ARE VERY
AND MOST RADICAL SOCIALIST
POSITIONS FROM POLICE TO
FRACKING.
THE CONSUMPTION OF RED MEAT AND
EVEN THE ELIMINATION OF STRAWS
AND ALL PRIVATE HEALTH CARE
PLANS.
THEY WOULD BE OUTLAWED IN HER
SUPPORT OF GUN BANS BY EXECUTIVE
FIAT.
ALSO VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE
WILL WEIGH IN STRAIGHT-AHEAD
BURIED BUT WE START IN
WILMINGTON, DELAWARE, WHERE
BIDEN SOMEHOW MANAGED TO TRAVEL
A FEW MILES AWAY FROM HIS
BASEMENT BUNKER TO INTRODUCE HIS
NEW RUNNING MATE AFTER, WHAT, A
THREE HOUR DELAY, AN EXTREMELY
LONG, MEANDERING SPEECH
DELIVERED WITH THE HELP OF HIS
TRUSTY TELEPROMPTER IN AN ALMOST
EMPTY GYMNASIUM.
JOE BIDEN FINALLY MADE IT
OFFICIAL AND DURING THE JOINT
EVENT, DIDN’T TAKE QUESTIONS
AFTER TRASHING PRESIDENT TRUMP,
PRODUCTIVELY.
OF COURSE BOTH BIDEN AND HARRIS
HEAPED SCRIPTED PRAISE ALL OVER
EACH OTHER.
IT WAS SO FAKE, SO BLATANTLY
PHONY THAT YOU COULDN’T HELP BUT
KIND OF CRINGE WHEN YOU KNOW THE
TRUTH.
THERE WAS ONLY A FEW MONTHS AGO
THAT KAMALA HARRIS WAS HEAVILY
SUGGESTING THAT JOE BIDEN WAS A
RACIST AND A SEXIST.
AMAZING HOW THINGS CHANGE IN
ELECTION YEARS, ISN’T THAT?
>> YOU ALSO WORKED WITH THEM TO
OPPOSE BUSING.
AND THERE WAS A LITTLE GIRL IN
CALIFORNIA WHO WAS PART OF THE
SECOND CLASS TO INTEGRATE HER
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
AND SHE WAS BUSED TO SCHOOL
EVERY DAY.
AND THAT LITTLE GIRL WAS ME.
HIS EMPATHY, HIS COMPASSION, HIS
SENSE OF DUTY TO CARE FOR
OTHERS.
IT IS WHY I AM SO PROUD TO BE ON
THIS TICKET.
>> THIS CHARACTERIZATION, I DID
NOT PRAISE RACISTS.
SHE KNOWS HOW TO GOVERN.
SHE KNOWS HOW TO MAKE THE HARD
CALLS.
SHE IS READY TO DO THIS JOB ON
DAY ONE.
>> PRAISING AND CODDLING
INDIVIDUALS WHO MADE IT THEIR
LIFE’S WORK AND BUILT THEIR
REPUTATION OFF OF SEGREGATION OF
THE RACES IN THE UNITED STATES.
THAT’S THE PROBLEM.
>> HIS EMPATHY, HIS COMPASSION,
HIS SENSE OF DUTY TO CARE FOR
OTHERS IS WHY I AM SO PROUD TO
BE ON THIS TICKET.
>> Sean: KAMALA HARRIS BACK
THEN WAS RIGHT, BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN PRAISED THE GUY THAT
ACTUALLY FILIBUSTER THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT AND OPPOSED THE
VOTING RIGHTS ACT.
AND WORK WITH THE FORMER
KLANSMAN ON THE ISSUE OF
STOPPING THE INTEGRATION OF
SCHOOLS AND SAYING HE DIDN’T
WANT HIS KIDS GOING TO SCHOOL IN
A "RACIAL JUNGLE," SO WHY WOULD
JOE BIDEN PICK A RUNNING MATE
WHO ALL BUT PRETTY MUCH CALLED
HIM RACIST OVER AND OVER AGAIN?
WHY WOULD HE PICK SOMEONE WHO
SAID I BELIEVE BIDEN’S
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT ACCUSER?
ALL OF THE ANSWERS, HARRIS IS A
FAVORITE OF THE RADICAL FAR LEFT
ESTABLISHMENT.
NEW YORK TOILET PAPER TERMS,
THEY CALLED HER A PRAGMATIC
MODERATE.
NO WAY, SHAPE, OR FORM.
THAT’S JUST ANOTHER OUTRIGHT LIE
BY "THE NEW YORK TIMES."
2019, SHE HAD THE MOST LIBERAL
VOTING RECORD OF ANY OTHER U.S.
SENATOR.
SHE WAS ACTUALLY TO THE LEFT OF
BOLSHEVIK BERNIE SANDERS.
SHE WAS THE COSPONSOR OF THAT
INSANE GREEN NEW DEAL AND MAYBE
THEY ARE JUST TRYING TO COVER UP
HIS CRAZY SOCIALIST AGENDA BY
GIVING CONGRESSWOMAN
OCASIO-CORTEZ A WHOPPING 60
SECONDS, WE FOUND OUT TONIGHT TO
SPEAK AT THE DEMOCRATIC
CONVENTION.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR KAMALA HARRIS,
SHE IS NOW ON TAPE PROMISING TO
BAN ALL FRACKING.
PENNSYLVANIA, ARE YOU PAYING
ATTENTION?
ON DAY ONE IN OFFICE, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> WILL YOU COMMIT TO IMPLEMENT
IN A FEDERAL BAN ON FRACKING
YOUR FIRST DAY IN OFFICE?
ADDING THE UNITED STATES TO THE
LIST OF COUNTRIES WHO HAVE
BANNED THIS DEVASTATING PRACTICE
GIMMICKS BECAUSE THERE’S NO
QUESTION I’M IN FAVOR OF --
>> Sean: THAT WOULD COST A
HALF A MILLION HIGH-PAYING JOBS
IN PENNSYLVANIA, YEAH, 100,000
PLUS JOBS IN OHIO, MILLIONS OF
OTHER JOBS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT WOULD SEND THE PRICE OF OIL
AND GAS, THE LIFEBLOOD OF OUR
ECONOMY, THROUGH THE ROOF AND
THERE’S A LOT MORE.
AS PART OF HER RADICAL SOCIALIST
AGENDA, HARRIS WOULD EVEN BAN
PLASTIC STRAWS AND LIMIT YOUR
CONSUMPTION OF RED MEAT.
I JUST LOVE WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
IS THERE TO TELL ME HOW TO LIVE
AND IF YOU LIKE YOUR DOCTOR, IF
YOU LIKE YOUR HEALTH INSURANCE
PLAN, WELL, YOU’RE GOING TO WANT
TO LISTEN VERY CLOSELY TO THIS
NEXT INSANE RADICAL SOCIALIST
CLIP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I BELIEVE THE SOLUTION AND I
ACTUALLY FEEL VERY STRONGLY
ABOUT THIS, WE NEED TO HAVE
MEDICARE FOR ALL.
THAT’S JUST THE BOTTOM LINE.
>> I BELIEVE IT WILL TOTALLY
ELIMINATE PRIVATE INSURANCE.
SO FOR PEOPLE OUT THERE WHO LIKE
THEIR INSURANCE, THEY DON’T GET
TO KEEP IT?
>> LISTEN, THE IDEA IS THAT
EVERYONE GETS ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CARE.
DO NOT HAVE THAT SITUATION WHERE
YOU’VE GOT TO WAIT FOR APPROVAL
WHEN THE DOCTOR SAYS WELL, I
DON’T KNOW IF YOUR INSURANCE
COMPANY IS GOING TO COVER THIS.
LET’S ELIMINATE ALL OF THAT,
LET’S MOVE ON.
>> Sean: ELIMINATE IT, MOVE
ON.
WOW.
THEN YOU’RE STUCK WITH
OBAMACARE.
HOW DID THOSE PROMISES WORKOUT?
HARRIS GETS HER WAY, OVER
200 MILLION AMERICANS WOULD HAVE
THEIR HEALTH INSURANCE STRIPPED
AWAY, NO CHOICE, NO OPTIONS.
I THOUGHT LIBERALS WERE
PRO-CHOICE.
APPARENTLY NOT ON THIS ISSUE.
AND OF COURSE YOUR TAXES, THEY
WILL GO THROUGH THE ROOF.
ALREADY PLOTTING MAJOR TAX
HIKES.
LET’S KEEP TRACK OF HIS MIND
PART OF A RADICAL AGENDA, SHE
WOULD CONFISCATE YOUR PRIVATE
HEALTH INSURANCE, YOUR INCOME,
YEP, IT EVEN SAYS BY EXECUTIVE
FIAT WE ARE GOING TO TAKE AWAY
SOME OF YOUR GUNS, YOUR PLASTIC
STRAWS, YOUR RED MEAT AND THAT
LIST GOES ON.
SHE WANTS THE GOVERNMENT TO
COMPLETE WOULD DICTATE EVERY
ASPECT OF YOUR LIFE.
THAT’S BECAUSE LIKE MANY OF THE
RADICAL SOCIALIST LEFT,
SENATOR HARRIS BELIEVES THAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ACTUALLY SAYS IT
ABOUT ONE PARTICULAR VOTING
BLOCK AND DEMOGRAPHIC ARE JUST
STUPID.
WELL, YOU DON’T BELIEVE ME,
LET’S GO TO THE VIDEOTAPE.
>> WHAT ELSE DO WE KNOW ABOUT
THIS POPULATION 18-24?
THEY ARE STUPID.
THAT IS WHY WE PUT THEM IN
DORMITORIES!
AND THEY HAVE A RESIDENT
ASSISTANT!
THEY MAKE REALLY BAD DECISIONS.
>> Sean: WHY DON’T WE JUST
LOCK THEM ALL UP UNTIL THEY ARE
25?
IF YOU WATCH THE OTHER SO-CALLED
NEWS NETWORKS OR READ ALMOST ANY
PAPER IN THE COUNTRY, YOU WILL
NEVER GET THE TRUTH ABOUT
SENATOR HARRIS.
YOU WILL NEVER SEE THESE CLIPS,
YOU WILL NEVER HEAR ABOUT HER
RADICAL POSITIONS AND HER
RADICAL RECORD.
THEY WILL LIE TO YOU DAY IN AND
DAY OUT FOR THE NEXT 83 DAYS AND
THEY WILL CONTINUE TO PUSH THE
LINE THAT SHE HAS A PRAGMATIC
MODERATE.
AT THIS POINT, THE MOB, THE
MEDIA HAS ABSOLUTELY ZERO
SELF-RESPECT AND THEY DON’T
CONCERN THEMSELVES WITH ANYTHING
THAT RECOGNIZES TRUTH.
THEY ARE NOW HARD-CORE STATIST
PARTISAN DEMOCRATS THAT WILL SAY
AND DO ANYTHING TO BEAT
DONALD TRUMP.
IT’S A CULT OF HATRED, A
PSYCHOSIS.
KIND OF HARD TO EXPLAIN
ACTUALLY.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT THEIR
VETTING OF KAMALA HARRIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> JUST BEING TOLD WE HAVE A
PICK AND ITS KAMALA HARRIS OF
CALIFORNIA.
JUST TOLD IN MY EAR AT THE
SECOND.
FOR THE RECORD, THOSE OF FLAWS
WERE FROM CLAIRE McCASKILL.
>> I THINK THAT KAMALA HARRIS
ADDS A LAYER OF ENERGY TO THE
BIDEN CAMPAIGN.
>> PEOPLE WANTED TO BE AROUND
HER.
THERE WAS A CHARISMA,
FASCINATION, FOR LACK OF A
BETTER WORD, ANDERSON, A BIT OF
CELEBRITY SURROUNDING
KAMALA HARRIS.
>> JOE BIDEN COULD HAVE CHOSEN
SOMEONE ELSE, BUT HE COULDN’T
HAVE CHOSEN ANYONE BETTER.
SHE IS CLEARLY A GREAT
CAMPAIGNER, BUT SHE’S ALSO GOOD
AT GOVERNING.
>> DEMOCRATS HAVE THOUGHTS AND
SHE STEPPED ONTO THE STAGE THAT
SHE HAD AN INCREDIBLY BRIGHT
FUTURE.
>> ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS, SHE
HERSELF A FIGHTER, RIGHT?
>> SHE’S AN ENERGETIC
CAMPAIGNER.
WOMEN’S VOTE, YOUNGER PEOPLE’S
VOTE.
ALL OF THIS BRINGS ENORMOUS
ENERGY.
>> Sean: ONE, PRETTY MUCH
ANYBODY WOULD HAVE MORE ENERGY
THAN, WELL, THE EVER FORGETFUL
JOE.
SEEMS LIKE HE NEEDS A NAP VERY
OFTEN AND SHE ONLY HAD 2% OR
LESS.
AT THE COVERAGE WAS SO BAD, SO
ABUSIVELY BIASED, ONE OF THESE
FAKE JOURNALISTS AND LUNATIC AT
FAKE NEWS CNN COMPLAINED THAT WE
WERE THROWING EVERYTHING BUT THE
KITCHEN SINK AT KAMALA HARRIS.
THAT’S ACTUALLY CALLED VETTING
THE CANDIDATE.
FAKE NEWS CNN MIGHT WANT TO TRY
IT OUT SOMETIME ON A DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE.
JUST THE CANDIDATE’S RECORD,
JUST THE EXACT THINGS WHICH THEY
HAVE SET IN THE POSITIONS
THEY’VE TAKEN WITH THE
ACCOMPANYING PROOF, THE VIDEO
AND AUDIO TAPES.
ESPECIALLY NOW, ALL OF THE
OBVIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT BIDEN’S
FRANKLY MENTAL ALERTNESS, ACUITY
FROM FITNESS FOR OFFICE, HIS
STRENGTH AND STAMINA.
GET THIS, THE MEDIA RAISED THOSE
QUESTIONS ABOUT 71-YEAR-OLD
JOHN McCAIN AND HIS AGE IN
2008.
THE RAISED QUESTIONS ABOUT
73-YEAR-OLD RONALD REAGAN DURING
HIS REELECTION BID IN 1984.
BY THE WAY, FOR THE RECORD,
BIDEN WOULD BE OLDER ON HIS
FIRST DAY OF OFFICE THAN REAGAN
WAS ON HIS LAST DAY OF OFFICE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I AM NOT GOING TO EXPLOIT FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES MY OPPONENT’S
YOUTH AND INEXPERIENCE.
>> Sean: CHECKMATE,
RONALD REAGAN WON 49 STATES.
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN THE MOB AND
THE MEDIA, THEY ARE ASKED A
QUESTION ABOUT 77-YEAR-OLD
BIDEN’S MENTAL ACUITY.
I’M NOT A DOCTOR, BUT HE LOOKS
KIND OF FRAGILE, TIRED, WEAK, TO
ME.
THESE CONSTANT EMBARRASSMENTS,
THEY ARE BEGINNING TO RAISE A
LOT OF SERIOUS QUESTIONS.
AND PEOPLE IN THE CONTRACT
TALKING ABOUT IT.
WHETHER THE MOB WANTS TO COVER
IT UP OR NOT, THE CONFUSION, THE
BOUTS OF ANGER.
ARE YOU A JUNKIE?
DID YOU GET TESTED FOR COCAINE?
COME ON, MAN.
ALMOST NO ONE OUTSIDE OF THIS
NETWORK EVEN SEEMS WILLING TO
SERIOUSLY BROACH THE SUBJECT.
WE WILL DO OUR JOB.
IN FACT, THEY ARE ACTUALLY
TRYING TO COVER UP HIS APPARENT
ISSUES.
OVER THERE AT STATE-RUN
CONSPIRACY TELEVISION MSDNC,
WELL, THEY SEEMINGLY ACTUALLY
CROPPED OUT WHAT APPEARED TO BE
A WRITTEN SCRIPT OF BIDEN AND
HAVING A CASUAL VIDEO
CONVERSATION WITH KAMALA HARRIS.
AND BY THE WAY, YOU CAN ACTUALLY
SEE BIDEN IN THAT PICTURE, HE’S
HOLDING THE PHONE UPSIDE DOWN.
AND ULTIMATELY THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN IS HOPING THAT
KAMALA HARRIS WILL BRING A
MUCH-NEEDED BOOST OF ENERGY,
CHARISMA, ALERTNESS, THAT BIDEN
CLEARLY LACKS.
THAT WAS THOSE ARE FUNDAMENTALS
FOR THE HARDEST JOB IN THE WORLD
AND IS ONE PROBLEM WITH THAT
THEORY.
KAMALA, WELL, SHE DOESN’T
CONNECT WITH VOTERS.
PRESIDENTIAL BID WAS A MASSIVE
FAILURE, A FLOP.
SHE DROPPED OUT IN DECEMBER
BEFORE ANY PRIMARY OR CAUCUS.
SHE WAS PULLING AT A MEAGER 2%
OR LESS.
ESPECIALLY AFTER TULSI GABBARD’S
TAKEDOWN.
EVEN IN HER HOME STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, SHE WAS PULLING IN
SINGLE DIGITS.
THEY KNOW HER BEST.
BUT FEAR NOT, THE MEDIA MOB, THE
CULT THAT THEY ARE, THAT HATES
TRUMP 24/7, ALL THEY WILL DO AND
SAY ANYTHING TO HELP LIFT HER
UP.
JUST TAKE A LOOK AT TODAY’S
FRONT PAGE, NEW YORK TOILET
PAPER TIMES, IT’S WORTHLESS.
BASICALLY AS GOOD AS TOILET
PAPER.
COMPARE IT TO THEIR COVERAGE IN
2016 A VICE PRESIDENT PENCE.
DONALD TRUMP’S CHOICE FOR A
RUNNING MATE.
AS WE HAVE SAID MANY TIMES ON